Today we're going to talk
about customer segments.
Who are you building your
value proposition for?
What jobs do they want to get done?
What pains do they want to solve and
what gains that they want to see?
And at the end of this, what you want to
find is what's the archetype work or
persona of who you're
building the product for.
Now the last time we talked
about value propositions, but
today we're going to focus
on customer segments.
One of the interesting
things about customers
is that customers don't exist to buy.
You actually exist for them.
And especially if you're a technology
startup, that's really hard because you
always think it's about your product and
it's hard to remember that it's actually
about the people on the other
side who are going to buy.
And so one of the things you really
need to understand is who are they and
why are they going to buy from you?
And one of the goals of
customer segments is trying to
understand the archetype or
the persona or
maybe just the details of who these
people are in specific detail.
You want to know where they live,
what do they do, what's their age,
are they in urban areas or
are they married, etc.?
And why do you want to know that?
Because it will help you figure out
how to not try to boil the ocean by
trying to get everybody in
the world to buy your product.
But figuring out who
specifically is interested and
why makes it incredibly easy to sell.
And have them want your product when
you understand who they are and
what their motivations are.
So that's why we spend all this
time talking about customers and
customer segments.
One of the things you'll also see
later in this lecture is that you
might actually have multiple
customer segments, that is,
different types of customers
all interested in your product.
They might be male 18 through
24 who live in urban areas.
But you might also have women
who live in the countryside,
45 to 55 in some cases, also interested.
And the types of marketing or
demand creation you'll do to attract
each segment will be different, but
if you didn't know who they were,
you'd be creating the same
type of marketing and
in fact probably not
reaching any of them.
So let's take a look at
this in more detail.